à la mort de la riche tante bertille la
branche faucher de la famille brigitte s
es enfants espérait bien profiter de
l'héritage mais bertinat mais pas trop
élevés alors tu ne parles pas que les
enfants entrent à des problèmes elle
préférait leurs cousines et loïc berthy
vous a déserté pour que jamais se perdre
de vue c'est très important la famille à
la famille 5 n'aura pas en soutenant
type à ça j'ai signé un bail de six mois
à nous aura fait chier jusqu'au bout et
de pédales on me liront cet argent elle
me charge de veiller sur vous enfin il
doit quand même autre chose à faire qu'à
veiller sur nous oui non pas du tout on
est tous majeurs et vaccinés on n'a pas
besoin de quelqu'un on a juste besoin de
thunes comprendre ce qui vous tient de
contrer tous ensemble vous présenter les
projets qui vous tiennent à coeur et
gravé et l'argent de berthier dedans
pourquoi tu fais tout ça pour nous et
loïse pour la première fois c'est moi
qui décide de tout cgt c'est vraiment
sûr que c'est pas fait acheter des
mauvais pressentiment temps de reprendre
les choses en main
[Musique]
quand même que c'est pas un gars raison
garder ses distances que j'en peux plus
moi c'est trop de pression
[Musique]
les choses s'arrangent toujours même mal